what are the chances that i don't get
kicked off twitter and youtube and
facebook just for talking to you
oh i think you have about a ten percent
chance a good solid ten percent
ten percent getting kicked off for ten
percent steady ten percent staying on
actually uh you know it's having an id
a government issued id which you need a
government issue id to buy beer or to
get on a plane or to rent a bicycle they
often want to see your id actually last
time i went mini golfing to rent the
golf club they wanted to see an id i
think they held the id actually because
they want to make sure you don't steal
the golf club so basically mini golf is
now more secure than our elections by
the way do you have to show an id to get
a covid vaccine
you probably uh you probably do they put
your name on a piece of paper racist
[ __ ] that they are
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white
entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they they don't have accountants
amela i'm uh reviewing my paperwork here
you are black is that correct i am
indeed that is very true i want to stay
for the record i don't see color dave
thank you go ahead
steve you are definitely not black i
mean i
do you have a lawyer or an accountant
and if not do you need help finding one
donald trump the guy who's no longer
president no longer on youtube no longer
on twitter facebook spotify instagram
pinterest or anywhere else
dealing with that guy who's completely
gone from everything
is the thing that is the biggest problem
for all of us despite many of us not
having jobs
and all the other bad stuff that's
happening in the world
donald j trump the impeachment begins
today if you send her jen pasaki what's
your favorite color i think she would
say four like the woman is completely
incapable of saying an honest direct
statement saki you're a liar you're a
liar and i don't know why it's left for
me to call you a liar i wish somebody
else would call you out in the
mainstream but i know you guys got those
people in your pockets because of say it
with me everybody democrat privilege
akin what have you learned sir
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay
uh think we love
i mean
the way that craig oh you know okay i
think we lost ken or ken what happened i
like this though oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that
should be that should be an msnbc show
you know any like right after bat out
you know and then she has to
like you know give them the transition
into oh [ __ ] [ __ ] so you know she's
babbling to the camera russia russia
russia trump trump trump coming up next
on oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're screwed everybody i'm basic [ __ ]
pumpkin spice conservatism i mean you
know it's not like anything that i
really believe is all that radical and
i've been here think of you as basic
[ __ ] yeah this is a clown car of
robbers breaking into neiman marcus
[Music]
freaking white supremacists it just
never stops with these people in our new
woke society
our safe and secure society we must
eliminate books like this you know this
thing is how many pages here you've got
uh oh it doesn't even have page numbers
it doesn't even have page numbers so you
guys would like that you wokesters
because i know you guys don't like math
so there's no page numbers on this thing
anyway he gets on a whole adventure and
figures out that he's got to do it on
his own and
lori lorre here in california we're
still not fully reopening until june
15th because gavin newsom is a [ __ ]
dirtbag piece of [ __ ] you know heading
back to garcetti's la and newsomes
california i'm sure it's going to fit
the breitbart editor-in-chief's persona
perfectly that's funny you're literally
the one guy who's going to replenish the
u-haul stock in california as
everybody's moving them across the
country you know you talk about the
impact of that day
but you guys won
you guys held
you know democracies
are not defined
by our bad days
thank you it's just because we've had a
bad day and
can i oh thank you and
we're just
[Applause]
oh wait that's the one we don't cry for
right biden also the other day was doing
a little press conference and he said he
was on the judiciary committee 150 years
ago which if that's true uh well
then then he's a vampire now i will read
some tweets about what's happening in
cuba from aoc ilhan omar and bernie
sanders
oh wait
there are none
but uh
there's you know there to be
you know beginning uh
we just move on to another question no
wait i don't understand this effort for
2021 is uh i think we've learned a few
lessons from last year as well
there's help us we they're
you know being there to help clear roads
rebuild
main streets
and so that the families can we move on
to another question are you sure uh yes
the way these i don't know if that was
an npr guy or it's a national post thing
or something but the way these
interviews the way they talk do you
think that
socialism is bad and like what's up with
cuba
i'm like can you tell me more about that
stuff like what's wrong with these
people can someone explain to me what
what happens i don't know if it is that
you it's the soy you're like ingesting
so much soy and next thing you know
here is the murderous governor of new
york andrew cuomo
and we have to get in those communities
and we have to knock on those doors
and we have to convince people and put
them in a car and drive them
and get that vaccine in their arm that
is the mission
you want buckle you want something
that is the mission god these people are
fools is there anyone more inauthentic
than than elizabeth warren remember i'm
gonna get me a beer i'm glad for
everybody who's joining this video it's
great to hear from hold on a sec i'm
gonna get me um
then she walks off camera on that little
live stream and that will never cease to
amaze me like really i think
sociologists and
psychologists
probably anthropologists
years from now should all study how
a billionaire orange man from new york
was more authentic than every single one
of the people who hated him that was my
only foray into politics other than when
i ran against william moore for fifth
grade class president
i took three out of four roles they're
still cleaning up the blood
knolls i told you abigail might be
coming to my house for an illegal party
next week nancy if you want to hop on a
plane you're welcome but noel's oh you
can't you can't come anymore you can't
come holes i'm sorry i'm gonna be the in
the name of inclusion and tolerance i
want you to let me in when i fly to l.a
hunter biden you may remember this guy
he is the crack smoking son of the
president of the united states
[Music]
i would imagine they were singing about
peace and coexistence and that sort of
thing they'll stay in this sort of
irrelevant limbo phase because i i've
met and i you know i know a lot of these
people and they just more than anything
else more than saving the country they
just don't want to be called
conservatives because you guys are very
scary you guys are very very scary big
show today guys okay so here we go i
mean i can't imagine anything is going
to happen with gwyneth paltrow is an
upstanding member of our hollywood
society this is a good woman you know
what i mean why would she have an
exploding vagina candle it's just crazy
but anyway i'm gonna go ahead here we go
i have a feeling we're going to do the
entire interview this way of course this
is we can't joke around no no this is
serious
yeah i don't want to kill your grandma
no thank you they're both dead well i
don't want to kill her again already
yeah yeah
have i already said too much that was
too much i've said too much
delete this
i think by ten percent that you
predicted about staying on youtube may
have just dropped i think
let me reduce it
[Music]
you